if you have two choices to make such as  do I tell this person a or do I tell  them b or do I uh you know do I take job  a or job b or do I make this sacrifice  now or do I go ahead and do what I want  whatever it is if you have two choices  and they're relatively equal choices  like it looks 50 50 to you this is key  your choice is where it's lopsided you  know 175 it was 25 obviously go to the  75. but if it looks equal to you A or B  and you can't decide take the path that  is more difficult and more painful in  the short term because what's actually  going on is one of these paths requires  short-term cleaning and the other one  maybe requires pain further out in the  future and what your brain is doing in  Conflict avoidance if it's trying to  push off the short-term pain and by  definition if the two are even and one  has short-term pain that means it has  long-term gains and by the law of  compound interest the long-term gain is  where you want to go towards anyway